all right what's going on guys this is
rob and i was i was looking over a lot
of the comments that you guys left from
the last video and you were talking
about the idea that scarlet witch is not
necessarily dead and that she's going to
come back and she's basically going to
get a redemption arc which after looking
over things and kind of thinking about
it i think you all are right so what i
want to do here is i want to give you
guys two stories and i want to juxtapose
these next to each other and i want you
to
to really let me know whether or not you
really think that's the direction that
things are going in right so i want you
to keep in mind the story of scarlet
witch as it's unfolded in the mcu so far
from the time she first appeared in a
post-credits scene until the events of
doctor strange ii and then i'm going to
give you the story of jean grey from
marvel comics up until the dark phoenix
saga and then i want you to let me know
if you think these two things are
basically identical but before we get
into that tim wanted to do our brand
integration for native so i will let tim
handle that and i will be back to you
guys here in a few minutes what's going
on guys this is tim and i am back and
some of you guys don't think i'm real
that's rude
i'm very real
absolutely i'm real
but uh rob's out running errands right
now he's mailing off
business
cards to his staff so uh yeah how did
you all like doctor strange too
when we went to go see the doctor's shoe
he freaked out when the x-men theme came
on rob absolutely lost it it was pretty
wild but uh yeah
did you guys like doctor strange too
what'd you think about it as i
understand it you guys are a little
mixed that's what rob was saying he said
some of you guys loved it some of you
guys hated it but uh
yeah however
there is something cool that i want to
show you all
check this out
so you guys have probably all heard of
native so they sent us more than we
expected they said they were focusing on
deodorant but they also sent us a body
wash which really smells good this one's
called like uh ginger lemonade cupcake
we were a little hesitant about it
because we didn't want to walk around
smelling like cupcakes all day and
getting hungry but it doesn't smell as
much like cupcakes as you would think it
smells really like light and airy and it
smells great but it doesn't smell like
vanilla cupcakes right so it didn't
really make us hungry all that much but
the deodorant is what they wanted us to
focus on right so normally whenever you
guys go to the store you get like those
plastic deodorant bottles and they've
got the little spin thing down at the
bottom and so on this is not like that
the one thing to know is because of all
their initiatives they're part of like
one percent uh for the planet so
basically one percent of all of their
deodorant sales go towards uh
environmental initiatives which is
really really cool um but these
containers like these deodorant
containers i don't know what else to
call them are basically hard paper so
literally you use it and then you
recycle it in lieu of having a little
spinny thing down here at the bottom
what you get instead is basically a push
pop effect so literally you just press
down at the bottom like this little
little thing right here you just press
that up and then it pushes up uh which
is cool so we we thought it was a really
really interesting idea uh one of the
things they wanted us to clarify which i
think kind of needs to be clarified um
is that the deodorant as you get it in
this container is basically the same
formula or not really basically but it
is the same formula they use in their
normal deodorant so you don't have to
worry about it like wearing off after 12
hours and a lot of people are probably
worried about that we were we were
concerned that like we would literally
put this deodorant on in the morning we
would go to the gym sometime during the
day and within an hour we'd be walking
around smelling like armpits uh we
didn't have that problem having said
that as far as the scents go um lilac
and white tea uh we're not necessarily
the biggest fans of it but that's
largely because
you know we're not really huge fans of
walking around smelling like flowers
it's not a bad scent it's just not for
us um the citrus and herbal musk is the
one that we love the most because it's
just light airy and it's it's it's great
especially now in the summer normally
whenever it's hot outside you don't want
to wear like super heavy fragrances of
any kind um and then the the cotton and
lily
we couldn't really smell it uh it had a
faint scent but not really enough that
we were like okay i mean it smells great
it just to us it almost smelled like a
deodorant that didn't have any scent now
maybe that's because our noses are not
necessarily as sensitive as other
people's um but nonetheless right the
the three that they gave us
um
it's definitely like there's a market
out there right like
people would enjoy these different
scents so if you're more of a fan of
like the flowery
light light smell then the white tea is
the one you want uh if you're a fan of
the citrus and herbal musk smell so
something a little stronger but lighter
and airier with a little bit of a fruity
hint that's the one that you want and
then if you
are a fan of like cotton and lily then
that one's for you but uh we like it and
we've been using these on a regular
basis and we're gonna keep on using
these because we're huge fans of
sustainability but yeah so like three of
those deodorants normally cost like 39
bucks uh but if you guys use our link in
the description and the coupon code
you'll get it for 26 bucks which is like
33 off which is an amazing deal plus you
can also get 20 off of toothpaste and
body wash by using our code if you click
the link in the description so it's
awesome but yeah let me know what you
guys thought about doctor strange too
let's get back into the video let's let
rob do his thing
i'm cooler than rob you know what i know
it let's all just admit it
okay hopefully tim didn't say anything
to you off the wall but uh so here's the
story of jean grey right so keep in mind
the story of scarlet witch but here's
the story of gene so when jean grey was
first introduced in marvel comics by
stanley and jack kirby she was useless
she was basically a damsel in distress
she could never do anything without
having to be saved by
cyclops basically now scarlet witch
wasn't necessarily like that but i think
we can unanimously agree that scarlet
witch in the early days of her
appearances in the marvel cinematic
universe outside of maybe a few moments
in like age of ultron
never really seemed to serve a practical
or useful purpose right and even when
she first was rolled over to the
avengers she was just kind of there and
did some stuff but she was by no means
the person that you would look to is
like the one who was gonna save the day
right like the tide turns because now
scarlet witch has entered the fight
that didn't come until avengers end game
but with jean grey she was the damsel in
distress she had to always be saved by
cyclops and that was used as a way to
create a romantic connection between the
two now fast forward to the mid-1970s
because the x-men comics under stanley
and jack kirby and arnold drake and roy
thomas just never succeeded nobody cared
so they basically they they axed it they
mixed it then they started writing news
stories in the 70s with giant size x-men
number one
enter chris claremont so chris claremont
was like jean grey sucks so we're going
to kill her we're going to kill her
character off but before we do we're
going to elevate her to just this insane
level of power and we're just going to
be like damn this girl really is as
powerful as we thought she was and she's
gonna go out with a bang and so what he
did is he wrote what was called the
phoenix and the dark phoenix sagas and
so what this did is it basically saw a
series of events where some of the x-men
were kidnapped they were taken to space
jean grey and others went to go rescue
the yada yada so on and so forth but in
essence when jean grey was coming back
to earth that she had essentially
reached out to the phoenix force in a
moment when all the x-men were basically
going to die they had hit these cosmic
waves but instead of them potentially
getting powers like the fantastic four
it was gonna kill him and so jean grey
reaching out to the phoenix force
basically allowed her to use the power
of the phoenix to essentially save
everybody now one big caveat to know
here is that the connection between gene
and the phoenix force had gone all the
way back to when she was a little girl
when her best friend annie was killed
and she had subconsciously reached out
and the phoenix force became aware of
her existence and that's when the
phoenix realized jean grey was the best
possible host across all the multiverse
for the full power of the phoenix and so
ever since that point in time it had
just been watching gene as she had grown
up when she first joined the x-men and
so when the events of the phoenix force
first kicked off it was wow okay so like
this is my chance for myself and gene to
basically finally unify for us to
finally merge our powers together and
become a singular being and so you had a
whole bunch of events that took place
right gene did her stuff with the
phoenix where she was basically learning
about her power and all that kind of
stuff and then there came a point when
she was hoodwinked she was duped that
this situation unfolded in such a way to
where she had basically been kidnapped
by what was called the hellfire club
among these members was a guy named
jason wingard they could basically
manipulate the five senses he could
trick gene grey into seeing whatever it
is that he wanted her to see right
controlling the five senses of the human
body over a course of series of events
she basically ended up becoming evil and
as a result of that she was
re-christened to the dark phoenix during
that point in time there was ultimately
a big battle between the x-men and a
race called the she are again we don't
necessarily need to get into the details
of that the important thing is that jean
grey realized that she had become the
villain that she had become the bad guy
and so in order to essentially save
everything in existence like literally
the universe and all of that she
sacrificed her life and she ultimately
ended up dying and so that was going to
be the end of g like literally done
forever we're never bringing her back
her popularity turned out to be so high
though that marvel ended up bringing her
back and what a lot of people kind of
look at is just sort of a controversial
story in the sense that when it was the
dark phoenix it wasn't actually gene it
was the phoenix
basically impersonating gene and jean
herself ever since she was flying the
space shuttle and crashed into earth had
just been sitting at the bottom of
jamaica bay that doesn't matter the
reason why i tell you this is because
that sounds almost identical to what's
going on with the scarlet witch when
wanda first showed up she didn't really
seem to serve a practical purpose she
was cool and she did some stuff whatever
and made people see like hallucinations
and like that was basically it the
equivalent of the phoenix saga story for
for wanda right instead of her flying a
space shuttle and potentially crashing
into earth and everybody dying but being
met by a cosmic being who can give her a
new source of power and she can save
everybody it's basically the death of
vision right the fact that she had to
destroy the mind stone in the head of
vision and essentially kill the man she
loved in order to prevent the mind stone
from being used by thanos to complete
the infinity gauntlet that right there
was the snap right that's literally when
she just started to lose it but she
hadn't quite gone off the rails yet she
was just discovering the fact that she
could do things that she didn't know she
could do before that continued discovery
of her power that was one division that
was literally her like bringing vision
like like recreating vision and then
creating her kids and giving herself the
life she always wanted even though she
knew it wasn't real and so if we say
that's the phoenix saga the catalyst for
her basically becoming the dark phoenix
that would be the end of wand division
having to give up her kids having to you
know watch vision be destroyed knowing
that white vision exists out there but
who the hell knows what he's doing maybe
we'll see him in thor love with thunder
i don't know but like that's that's the
catalyst right the thing that that
basically made her mind snap where she
essentially went nuts right wanda over
the course of what's going on in doctor
strange two is her equivalent of the
dark phoenix saga becoming just
straight-up evil just a pure straight-up
evil person fighting the people that she
once considered to be friends all in
some mad quest to achieve a particular
goal which cannot necessarily be
achieved and then coming to the
realization she literally is the villain
of her own story right she's the bad guy
here you know it took her kids being
terrified of her for her to realize that
but that's that's her kind of building
up to the dark phoenix so the question
is if that's the case what's her
redemption arc and what's that art going
to look like is it going to conclude in
the death of you know the scarlet witch
my answer to that question is yes
scarlet witch is going to die but she's
not dead in doctor strange too i think
she's alive now elizabeth olsen came out
recently she was on good morning america
and she totally shot down the idea of
there being a scarlet witch solo film
which makes the most sense because i
think that what they're doing is the
redemption arc of the scarlet witch is
gonna go into the multiverse right if we
build on this idea that what they're
essentially doing is taking the story of
the phoenix and applying it to wanda and
she while not necessarily possessing the
phoenix force has the same like new
level of power learning about that power
becoming a villain and then getting that
redemption arc then i would in turn say
that her her whole redeeming thing is
going to be something akin to what was
what was covered in grant morrison's
here comes tomorrow when the phoenix
force basically revealed that like its
purpose is to quote unquote fix what's
broken and now that wanda has dabbled in
the multiverse and is aware of the
multiverse and you know most likely
during that time when she was meditating
and dream walking and all that kind of
stuff expanding her power even though
she may not necessarily know that she's
doing it she's now entered into the
multiverse but she's not a bad guy
anymore most likely it would be
exploration find out what's going on out
there now i don't think she's going to
be like you know shanghaied and become
like an agent of king but what i could
certainly see happening is marvel
basically building on this idea that
king and the incursions are two separate
events that neither one has to do with
the other that if kang does have
anything to do with the incursions is
because he's just letting all these
newly created you know realities or
newly created timelines just spiral out
of control but it's not anything in
particular he did that created the
incursions if anything it'd be sylvie
from loki and so if wanda's learning
about that what better redemption arc
for the character of wanda for her to
literally be this being of a multiversal
level of power and try to fix everything
and say like the multiverse is broken we
have to fix it and even if she can't die
trying if anything right if if wanda
doing that and then dying in the process
and still not succeeding if anything
would solidify the extreme nature of the
incursions the fact that it can't be
fixed or if if anything could solidify
the power of kang in terms of how
dangerous he is because remember
everyone from fighty to sam raimi to
everybody who is involved in doctor
strange 2 and the future plans of the
mcu they've all literally been saying
thanos has nothing on king king is a
whole different level and all the
villains that we're going to start
seeing in the future of the mcu are
going to be way beyond thanos with the
infinity gauntlet right if all of that
is true what better way to showcase that
than to literally have wanda die trying
to fix the multiverse and essentially
have no recourse for the power of
someone like kang i mean how do you
defeat a guy who essentially exists in
every moment in time or can appear in
any moment in time not only that the
incursions themselves i don't think
those can be stopped because what i've
been saying up to this point is that at
the moment
marvel studios and all them you know
disney owns the rights to fox so the
fantastic four exists out there we
already saw reed and doctor strange too
and the earth 838 universe he doesn't
technically exist in the uh in the the
main marvel cinematic universe at the
moment maybe the new fantastic four
movie will fix that we don't entirely
know we know that xavier exists as part
of the illuminati but as far as we're
aware there's nothing to indicate the
x-men exist in the main marvel cinematic
universe what i've been saying all this
time is that they're going to find a way
to essentially collapse the entirety of
the multiverse down to a singular
universe and that's where everybody's
going to reside right literally the
survivors from those realities or
they're just going to reset everything
right they're going to be like new
timeline you know and now the x-men are
here and then so on and so forth right
whether or not they reboot i have no
idea it'd be a smart move right so that
way you're not continually building on
an existing universe endlessly and
essentially trying to find new ways to
tell stories because after a while you
run out of content you can only tell so
many spider-man stories before it always
just turns into peter webbing somebody
up and handing the cops right you can
only fight so many magical beings so
many magical demons and so on and so
forth so eventually they will have to
reboot but if they don't it'll be a way
to kind of consolidate everything down
but i think that would be the redemption
arc for for wanda right that
potentially
she could be the catalyst for that right
the incursion's happening the multiverse
everything kind of going nuts that she's
just like
no more alternate universes and
everything condenses down into a
singular timeline and that's how you end
up getting the x-men the fantastic four
all those alternate reality fox
properties that exist out there
somewhere in the ether they're all
condensed down into a singular universe
and that if the idea isn't to
necessarily reboot that they're all
helpless in the power of wanda so sure
she stops the incursion she saves the
multiverse at the expense of the
multiverse itself but she basically ends
up grabbing or or whoever it survives
ends up making it right so literally
like reed from some alternate reality
out there is back right maybe she brings
that brings back the illuminati who
knows i have no clue but i could
certainly see that being like the final
moment right the redemption arc of wanda
no more multiverse right literally just
a singular timeline and that's basically
it that fulfills the idea or the desire
that fan that we as fans have to have
that basically no more mutants moment uh
even though it wouldn't really apply to
mutants but to have like that that
three-word statement from wanda that
just totally resets everything right
just totally like clears everything out
and sets things back to zero because we
all want that i mean ideally it would be
wanda saying more mutants
but it would seem a little forced to do
that right it would just kind of come
out of nowhere but to have a moment
where wanda is like no more multiverse
that would be great i think it'd be
phenomenal and maybe she dies in the
process of doing that right exhausts all
of her power to essentially destroy the
multiverse and condense it all down to a
singular universe maybe that's the only
way they can defeat kang or something
along those lines who knows but i think
that'll be the the redemption arc of
wanda that shall be the means by which
the incursions and all that stuff come
to an end but let me know what you guys
think down in the comments section right
do you think that's a legitimate
possibility here are you just kind of
like
you know she'll probably die fighting
king who knows i mean i know the super
hardcore comic comic book fans like me
who love secret wars probably want to
see the beyonders i doubt we'll see them
right just a little too much even for
the mcu but let me know what you guys
think down in the comments section thank
you all for watching i will catch you
all later
peace